chaque année on voit défiler des
millions de photographies un petit peu
partout je prends vous prenez des
milliers de clichés de nos familles de
nos voyages de personnes qu'on croise
qu'est ce que deviennent ces images pour
ma part j'essaye à chaque fois de faire
l'aller retour de rendre ces images de
rendre ces sons que je capte un petit
peu partout dans le monde
vers les personnes qui me les ont offert
il ya quelques années je suis en irlande
du nord à côté de belfast pour assister
à une réunion ce qu'on appelle des
femmes de mères des femmes courageuses
en lutte qui sont là pour défendre leurs
droits pour défendre les droits de leurs
maris pour défendre leur implication
leur intégration dans certaines lois
européennes qui les oublie complètement
l'humeur est magnifique très bel accueil
moment de pause un petit peu comme ici
moment de pause où tout le monde part je
décide de partir à côté de belles phases
dans un petit port de pêche et je
rencontre une famille je rencontre une
famille un père et sa fille on commence
à discuter à échanger on s'entend bien
il naturellement le père me demandais ce
que tu peux me prendre en photo avec ma
fille j'ai pas de photos de nous deux
voilà il me tend son appareil photo
l'appareil photo ne fonctionne pas je
dis bah je vais prendre en photo avec le
mien je le prends en photo avec sa fille
alors je travaille en argentique avec
des pellicules à l'ancienne donc ils
demandaient ce que je peux voir la photo
judy non je peux pas te montrer la photo
mais je te l'envoie en échange de email
tout se passe bien je rentre à paris je
fais développer les pellicules je
regarde mes planches contacts une photo
a raté une photo à peu près réussi et je
me dis je vais le renvoyer
hélas impossible de trouver les mails
impossible de trouver le numéro de
téléphone donc je contacte les femmes de
mères cette association à qui un petit
peu en europe
un petit peu partout en europe je
contacte des gens dans le village
personne ne connaît ce père est cette
fille
et pour moi au bout de ça faisait déjà
une dizaine d'années que je travaillais
comme ça avec ces échanges ces allers
retours entre les personnes que je
photographiais que j'enregistrais et
leur retour et les nouvelles histoires
qui étaient proposées au travers de ces
échanges c'est c'est témoigner comme un
échec pas un échec professionnel je m'en
fiche
enfin la limite que n'ai pas d'histoire
derrière qu'ils soient publiées dans la
presse qui sont entendus à la radio
comme un échec personnel parce que ces
personnes m'avaient fait confiance
m'avait offert une partie de leur
histoire
elle veut faire une partie de leur vie
et j'avais envie d'aller plus loin avec
ces personnes mais pour l'instant c'est
un échec
quelques années plus tard je me rends en
géorgie je rencontre ces jeunes à
tbilissi dans le caucase qui sont en
train de faire de la danse de danser
dans le métro d'être bbc ont commencé à
échanger on commença il commence à
parler de l' échange entre la france
entre la georgie il commence à me parler
d'alexandre dumas
il commence à m'enseigner l'histoire de
leur pays que je connaissais absolument
pas on pousse les singes un petit peu
plus loin et chaque étape de mon travail
et comme ça je vais en reportage je
rencontre des personnes on se renvoie
nos sont ils me renvoient aussi parfois
des photos de moi qui permettent
d'échanger aussi où je leur parle de ma
vie ici et en 2007
on m'envoie à tombouctou on m'envoie
attendons tous pour les nations unies
les nations unies nos impôts vos impôts
filant sans en outre entre autres à part
dont un certain nombre de programmes
pour sensibiliser des personnes dans le
monde entier à la préservation de leur
patrimoine
la préservation de leur patrimoine bâti
comme ces mosquées dont vous avez dû
entendre parler lors de la dernière
guerre au mali certaines certains
mausolée ont été détruits mais aussi les
patrimoines vivants ce qu'on appelle les
patrimoines vivants c'est les comptes
c'est les petites histoires que de les
personnes se raconte au fil des siècles
et qui se transmettent ma position de
reporter à chaque fois est d'enregistrer
ces histoires de l'est
rapportés en france aux états unis en
europe pour les transmettre à d'autres
personnes
ce qu'on me demande à chaque fois c'est
de mettre en lumière ces histoires mais
il ya juste un petit détail qui m'embête
à chaque fois dans ce travail c'est que
ces personnes que je photographie ces
personnes qui me confient qu'ils
m'offrent leur histoire qu'est ce
qu'elle voit de cette production est ce
que le petit garçon en blanc en bas de
la photo il connaît l'histoire des deux
autres petits garçons qui sont sac à dos
en train d'aller à l'école de revenir de
l'école j'en suis pas sûr est ce que la
femme qui se retourne elle est au
courant de l'histoire de l'imam dans ce
dans cette mosquée j'en suis pas sûr
est ce que j'ai observé lors de ce
voyage en 2005 à tombouctou
c'est que tous les jeunes n'avaient pas
de réseau portable
en revanche ils avaient tous des
téléphones portables dernier cri et
comment est ce qu'ils faisaient pour
échanger avec leurs téléphones portables
ils utilisaient le protocole bluetooth
je vais pas si vous voyez ce que c'est
que le protocole bluetooth pour échanger
des fichiers sans réseau ou se sont
inventé leur propre réseau d'échangé de
communication dans le sahara
il suffit qu'une personne soit 3 4
mètres d'une autre personne et elle peut
lui passer une photo lui passé une vidéo
lui passer un son je suis venu à paris
avec cette idée est aussi en a et ayant
téléchargé par bluetooth
des clips de rap sahraouis des clips des
musiques qui m'ont offert là bas je suis
allé voir l'unesco et le cnu dans le
plan ii des nations unies pour le
développement
et je leur ai dit est ce qu on
n'utiliserait pas le bluetooth plutôt
que vos réunions il ya 50 ministres et
et quinzaine d'hommes politiques de
chaque pays
pourquoi est-ce qu'on utiliserait pas le
bluetooth au sahara pour transmettre ce
que nous donc ce que nous reporter pour
les nations unies enregistrons et score
est-ce qu'on peut pas leur donner aux
personnes au même moment
un de mes amis étaient en train de
développer des cannes pour aveugles qui
permettent aux aveugles de détecter via
un protocole bluetooth
certains obstacles qu'ils ne peuvent pas
voir d'habitude ça consiste en des
petits boîtiers comme deux télécommandes
comme ça qu'ils émettent des signaux
auprès des aveugles
il était en train de développer un
protocole pour permettre d'émettre pas
uniquement des vibrations pas uniquement
de la parole mais aussi des vidéos
cet ami m'a aidé à découper les vidéos à
les intégrer les vidéos que j'avais
filmé sur les patrimoines de tombouctou
sur les patrimoines chanter surtout m'a
permis de les intégrer dans ses boîtiers
bluetooth et je suis reparti à
tombouctou avec ses boîtiers j'ai deux
nouveaux films et là bas j'ai de nouveau
intégré des des vidéos dans l'est dans
le boîtier bluetooth et une fois que les
boîtiers était suffisamment plein de
vidéos on les installer un petit peu
partout dans la ville
plutôt aux endroits où aussi les jeunes
échangeaient des vidéos de rap des
vidéos qui n'avait rien à voir avec
tombouctou
le ministre est venu pour inaugurer le
protocole bluetooth dans tombouctou le
grand imam de la mosquée de tombouctou
est venu ils ont réussi à échanger leurs
carnets vin reste respectifs dans le
protocole bluetooth pendant que toute la
population des jeunes de tombouctou
était en train de télécharger toutes ces
patrimoines et quelques années plus tard
on fait un bond de 1500 km on va
tamanrasset en algérie
je me retrouve sur le marché légal de la
musique en algérie et je retrouve
certaines des vidéos que j'ai filmé mais
certains il y avait ajouté des sous
titres certains y avait ajouté d'autres
musiques qui était absolument pas
conforme aux nations unies on va dire
cet aller retour a permis en fait aux
images de circuler a permis à certaines
légendes qui disparaissent à certains
comptes qui disparaissent de circuler
dans le sahara de circuler au delà du
sahara quand on vient en tant que
reporter on prend beaucoup on nous offre
beaucoup mais on rend très peu
on voit grâce au développement de la
téléphonie portable ou sahara une
émergence d'idées parfois le réseau
passe pas mais c'est pas grave y'a une
invention de nouveaux réseaux et à
chaque fois sur chaque projet avec
d'autres amis on essaye au sahara et
dans d'autres régions du monde
on essaye d'utiliser ces technologies
pour rendre ce que l'on nous offre sur
le terrain il ya quelques années
le sahara est devenue zone rouge c'est
devenu une zone où on entendait parler
de terrorisme
on entendait parler d'enlèvement on
entendait parler de compagnies minières
qui sont en train de polluer absolument
tous les sols mais on entendait pas
parler de la vie réelle des saharien sur
12 millions de kilomètres carrés il ya
en effet des endroits dangereux sur 12
millions de kilomètres carrés 12
millions de kilomètres carrés j'ai pas
si vous voyez moi je vois pas c'est vous
prenez la mauritanie vous allez au
soudan voilà vous traversé toute
l'afrique sur une bande très large il
n'y a pas la guerre partout loin de là
il ya des entrepreneurs
il ya des jeunes hypra connectés il ya
des jeunes qui ont envie qui ne rêve pas
uniquement de venir en europe mais qui a
envie de développer leur pays il ya
énormément de population qui ne souhaite
plus reposer uniquement sur l'aide
humanitaire sur les ong sur les projets
qui viennent de l'étranger
et parmi ces jeunes un certain nombre de
musiciens il se trouve que les hasards
de la vie ont fait que je rencontre un
certain nombre de ces musiciens de
groupes comme tinariwen de groupes comme
bon binôme des gens avec qui on se
voyait très naturellement sahara ils
étaient soit chauffeur pour certaines
personnes il était soit c'était soit des
lieux d'hébergement et ces personnes
avaient utilisé la muse la musique pour
développer leurs revendications
politiques vous avez peut-être entendu
parler des rébellions touareg mais il ya
plein d'autres revendications au sahara
la revendication pour avoir un avenir
comme ici la revendication
pouvoir avoir une université ya pas une
université sur 12 millions de kilomètres
carrés ce qui peut paraître incroyable
toutes ces personnes essayé développer
ça en revanche il avait acquis entre eux
une connaissance des nouvelles
technologies incroyable il avait acquis
entre une connaissance de l' échange de
ces fichiers et il me poussait à
témoigner de cela
donc j'ai décidé de monter un projet qui
s'appelle sarah rocks à la fois rocks
pour le rock
évidemment mais aussi rocks en anglais
qui veut dire le sahara tremble le
sahara est en train de vibrer il ya
toute une énergie où on est loin d'être
dans une zone de dunes de beaux touareg
pierres sur leurs chameaux habillée tout
en bleue
on est dans une zone de vie avec des
envies d'études avec des envies
matérialiste avec des envies de réussite
avec des envies aussi de de sortir de
cette image et bambino que vous voyez là
en photo
en ce moment il est aux états unis en
train de jouer avec keith richard's il
est en train de jouer avec bob dylan
il est en train de jouer avec tous les
plus grands musiciens au monde mais lui
même est devenu prisonnier de cette
image de représentants de la culture du
sahara et il me le dit médias arnaud
c'est hyper sympa de vouloir bosser sur
les musiciens au sahara debout vouloir
transmettre cette idée que grâce à la
musique on peut avoir une autre image du
sahara mais il faut montrer aussi
l'autre ça soit dit en passant quand je
cherche un éditeur pour un livre on me
répond automatiquement dans mais ça se
vend pas le sahara réel à ce qu'on veut
c'est le sahara mythique c'est le sahara
des années 30 c'est le sahara collomb
c'est le sahara touristique est homo
pouces et comment est ce qui me pousse à
chaque fois que je photographie à chaque
fois que j'enregistre un son j'utilise
les réseaux sociaux en ce moment ils
sont complètement dingue de whatsapp et
whatsapp au sahara est en train de fin
de
vraiment bousculé toutes les habitudes
qu'il avait pris avec facebook et il me
critique il me critique en négatif
évidemment forcément aimé il me critique
aussi en positif il me pousse à aller
plus loin que le petit pneus qui a au
bord de la route parce qu'évidemment au
sahara ya plein d'histoires et ce petit
pneus qui à haubourdin au bord de la
route
c'est une piste pour faire du trafic en
fait c'est à dire vous sortez de la
route
c'est l'indication pour faire du trafic
donc évidemment en tant que reporter ça
m'intéresse un petit peu excitants à des
trafiquants qui franchissent les
frontières
donc ils disent non il n'ya pas que ça
il n'y a pas que des fraudeurs il ya
aussi des jeunes qui se lève qui se
bougent qu'ils sont connectés comme
rocard qui habite maintenant à bamako au
mali et qui fait partie de cette
jeunesse complètement connecté qui est
en demande de notre retour du retour de
nos images pour pouvoir sur réagir ici
on entend tout le temps parler de mass
medias mass medias essayer de convaincre
le plus grand nombre par des
informations par des tweets par des like
sur facebook lé plus tu as de like sur
facebook le plus tu diffusion
d'informations rokia bambino un certain
nombre de personnes à saramon convaincu
de l' inverse quand je publie un
reportage quand je diffuse des photos
quand je publie un livre je ne diffuse
pas pour le plus grand nombre
je te diffuse d'abord pour rocha pour
mon binôme pour tous leurs amis pour
qu'ils voient mon regard qu'ils puissent
m'apprendre à chaque fois je diffuse
pour leur communauté
personne ne veut parler de la réalité de
leur communauté
je vais être franc on est quatre ou cinq
dans le monde entier à vouloir
uniquement par les hormis les chercheurs
a parlé du sahara telle qu'il est le
reste c'est des personnes qui pour des
questions économiques accepte ce que les
rédactions ce que les éditeurs ce que
les télévisions leur demande à savoir un
sahara de guerre 1 sarah de famine
un sahara qui existe on n'est pas
complètement irréaliste on le voit on
participe à des actions discrètement
pour aider certains coins mais ce n'est
pas l'ensemble du sahara c'est des
petits coins très particulier et ces
jeunes pas que des jeunes d'ailleurs
m'ont poussé à faire une somme à essayer
de sortir un livre de publier un livre
autour de ce projet sarah rocks donc je
leur ai dit ça marchera jamais il n'y a
pas d'éditeur voilà heureusement il ya
un éditeur un breton elle c'est fou pour
pour se lancer dans le pari mais il
fallait un petit peu d'argent donc on a
lancé une campagne de crowdfunding donc
je suis allé voir tous les copains
comment on fait une campagne au
crowdfunding il faut que tu mobilise des
communautés toute attaque les
communautés en quinze ans de voyages de
reportages elle était devant moi mais je
les voyais pas et ce sont eux qui m'ont
dit mais tu sais on nous ya les touareg
mais aussi les arabes du sahara qui
aussi les haoussas au niger et toutes
ces personnes m'ont encouragé ils m'ont
dit ouais tu peux pas nous faire des
pare-soleil pour nos 4 4 parce que là en
ce moment la mode c'est uniquement des
versets du coran et tu peux pas nous
faire des trucs sahara rocks et on se
prend en photo devant sinon je peux pas
je vais pas je vais pas aller à
l'encontre des des versets du coran en
revanche je sais pas inventer des trucs
ils sont bien m'envoyer depuis les camps
de réfugiés sahraouis entre le maroc et
l algérie depuis agadez
chacun s'est emparé du projet sahara
rocks j'ai terminé le livre et je suis
arrivé à un moment assez critique où je
les aimais j'ai rendu ce qu'on m'avait
offert mais est-ce que je peux pas leur
faire faire en sorte qu'ils se posent
même des questions est-ce qu'on peut pas
faire en sorte que on a eu un petit peu
plus loin que ces jeunes qui se posent
des questions et est-ce qu'on peut pas
leur proposer le sahara pour toi dans
vingt ans c'est quoi donc je leur ai
posé la question et la question à
circuler sur tous les réseaux sociaux
pas sûr tender comme tout à l'heure on
en parlait mais sur énormément de réseau
qu'est ce que sera le sahara dans 20 ans
toute cette histoire pour vous
prouver que en offrant les photos en
rendant les sons en offrant à chaque
fois que vous voyagez des choses aux
personnes que vous rencontrez d'autres
histoires vous arrive vous créer des
communautés qui vous entourent qui vous
encouragent qui vous critiquent qui vous
font progresser ici cette communauté qui
est aujourd'hui dans cette salle peut me
permettre de retrouver ces deux
personnes
ce père et sa fille je pense que c'est
une bonne petite philosophie de voyage
de quand vous voyagez quand vous prenez
des photos
baran délais et vous pouvez prendre en
photo cette personne elle est diffusée
merci